في الانتخابات البلديه الماضيه دعم حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي مرشحين معارضه في المدن
الكبرى كانقر واسطنبول فخسر مرشح لائتلاف
حاكم هذه المدن لاول مره منذ عقدين دعم
الحزب ذي الغالبيه الكرديه كان حاسما هذه
المعادله لن تتغير في الانتخابات القادمه
من ناحيه الشكل لكنها تغيرت لجهه مضمون
لم يستطع الحزب الذي يحظى بدعم في المناطق
الكرديه من الانضمام لتحالف الامه المعارض
لرفض حزب الخير القومي المتشدد وزعيمته
ميرال اكشنر التعامل العلني والمباشره مع
الحزب لان القوميين ينظرون اليه كامتداد
لحزب العمال الكردستاني لكن في المقابل لم
تمانع اكشنر من تواصل شريكها في تحالف
الامه كمال كلجدار اوغلو مع قاده الحزب
الكردي لكسب ودهم وضمان تاييدهم وفق هذه
المعادله بقيت العلاقه بين تحالف الامه
وحزب الشعوب قائمه لسنوات تعاون من تحت
الطاوله ودعم كردي لمرشحي التحالف لكن حزب
الشعوب الذي اراد اعترافا علنيا بدوره
وحقوق الاكراد من قبل تحالف الامه يدرك
تماما استحاله انضمامه لهذا التحالف لذلك
قرر تش التحالف العمل والحريه جاذبا اليه
احزابا يساريه صغيره
الاستبيانات والاحصاءات بالاضافه الى
الدورات الانتخابيه السابقه اظهرت بلا
ادنى شك بان الاصوات الكرديه المحسوبه على
حزب الشعب الديمقراطي هي عنصر توازن مهم
في الانتخابات وعليه ستبقى الاصوات
الكرديه عنصرا مهما وسيكون لها دور كبير
في تحديد مسار التصويت ينصب هدف هذا
التحالف مباشره على الانتخابات البرلمانيه
ودخول البرلمان باكبر عدد من النواب لكنه
فضل عدم طرح مرشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه
ودعم مرشح تحالف الامه كمال كالجدار اوغلو
ضد اردوغان فكل التحالفين يريدان ازاحه
اردوغان عن المشهد
الكردي يمتاز بوعي سياسي عال يمكنه من
تحديد مصلحته في الانتخابات وحزبنا يثق
بوعي الناخب الكردي الذي سيتجه نحو
التصويت لصالح المرشح الذي يختاره الحزب
ساعات الجدار اوكلو بقوه للحصول على دعم
هذا التحالف عبر تقديمه وعودا قاطعه
بمناقشه القضيه الكرديه في البرلمان لكن
مدى استجابه الاكراد لدعوه التحالف
بالتصويت لزعيم المعارضه لا يبدو واضحا
حتى اللحظه فحسابات الانتخابات البلديه
لدى الناخب تختلف تماما عن حساباته في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات